spero a emma proprio long per tutti
ragazzi e bentornati sul gas gori
mammamia ragazzo passati 20 mila anni
allora ragazzi ho visto ho visto che ci
sono delle robe nuove effettivamente da
fare come ad esempio i nuovi livelli che
proprio non ho mai fatto perché non li
ho giocati prima e quindi direi di fare
12 episodi non so quanto durera
effettivamente con i ragazzi tipologia
che gi oh
ma è tutto allegro beh almeno si sta
divertendo cela la faccia sembra che sia
tutto a posto
che triste ma lì attaccata con la colla
vinilica allora in teoria sto gioco e un
pelo più
ecco infatti quello che stavo per dire
ci sono delle rock
[Musica]
l'avessero dato non è femminile qualcuno
pensò che si fosse capito allora ragazzi
sta parte un pò un casino ma ci provo
tutto ok tutto che è tutto a posto non è
successo niente di complicato secondo me
as this il nice in via ok sono le lame
rotanti nove pezzi un piede lo dovrà
lasciare la forza che avevo scritto ci
stanno le macchine qua potrebbe essere
un problema non solo non capisco cosa
sia successo di prova niente
l'esca primo livello fatto non vedo
criticità anzi allora ragazzi questo era
un po l'inizio un po tutorial perché
effettivamente il primo livello è sempre
molto easy ma sappiate che sto gioco non
è solo problemi li prendi anche poco
facile
credo che sia successo qualcosa che non
sarebbero ok ma donna stava arrivando un
cerchione in faccia la tipa bella bella
già fatta bella ce l'ha fatta però tutti
i ragazzi ok perfetto
bene bene tutto a po tutto ok tutto a me
capodanno tranquilli tratto è cascata
una mina non si sa dove
fammi capire un attimo ok era buona
parte difficilissima perché per il resto
sollecita a fare tutto ho perso solo una
gamba ma fa niente
va bene europee vabbè madonna quella
mattina ha girato in modo pazzesco non
me ne ero accorto ma vado meglio con la
gamba sola e quello al fatto ragazzi po
strano ma è così
ma schivo le macchine niente di
particolarmente
saranno tranne che certo c'è poi qua o
ragazzino sono più morto la prima
incredibile va beh in realtà nello
spettacolo veloce madonna così scriveva
pe e vabbè volo volo volo volo è
impossibile non ho iniziato a volare
perché mi si era staccato il cosino
sopra il che è incredibile è il
traguardo dai ma casa ce l'ho fatta ce
lo fa quando diciamo multiamo zumbo di
bandiere così giusto perché mi stanno
sul culo però vabbè proviamoci vinci mi
ragazzi giorni jimi da un sacco che non
li uso c'è proprio l'amico
quelle sono le amanti che hanno scoperto
che avevo altre amanti tesoro mi sembra
un po eccessivo
mato mato quello appreso non son gradino
una roba che non so cosa ci è andata di
culo nella maniera pazzesca cose stanno
schianta dietro occhio occhio che non mi
ricordo dove arrivavano le altre
macchine rivendico ok ok ok va bene sarò
altre sono altre mancano 100 metri e
quella si è schiantata ma ora gioca ce
l'ho fatta genova a 0
no il traguardo della nova beh non ci
credo e tutto indietro ma sei scemo no
ragazzi il traguardo al dottore indietro
ma cosa
ciao zia alla prossima nicchia
posso provare a farlo solo perché sono
scassate ma a quanto pare non lo sono
tutte no rega impossibile cedevo
schivarla con gli con gli alberi non lo
so io ti prego no troppo fatta 79
ragazzo male aiuto aiuto cielo pietro no
oddio sono vivo aspetta aspetta
6 tutte quante le amanti chapra il terzo
leggibile avremo ancora concerne jimi
perché vedo che sono andati abbastanza
bene allora questa è partita abbastanza
tranquilla
però vedo che è pieno di ostacoli là
davanti proprio tranquillo non stato
apposto
tutto ok questo è un po difficile però
va bene a c'era anche il porca vacca
c'era anche il capo dello stato pur al
cavo mi sembra un po eccessivo però va
bene va bene tutto ok a destra dove
tristi capannoni ma non li vedo io in
quello che voleva ora i perfetto la fin
qua ci siamo fin qua ci siamo ad uscire
madonna lo fanno al contrario dio no
questo difficile ragazzi ma io ne soffre
un sacco ste cose non so perché questo
ragazzi abbastanza complicato ma non
impossibile forse lo passare
sull'esterno sai è l'unica infatti devo
andare basta andare piano
ehi madonna rega che ansia però succede
con ovviamente scilla tevi tranquilli e
la parlata omaggio trumpy tranqui a
posto sono una gamba in meno ma non fa
niente
e bello che c'è una musichetta
tranquillo dove va il ginocchio non sono
un miliardo e mezzo di mile che io
scriverò così ok nice hand aj mi sono
anche [ __ ] il traguardo guarda questo
livello si chiama all'infinito a lo puoi
fare anche con qualcun altro meno ma
dalla pro am
mi sembra un attimo eccessivo farlo con
devo centrare il prima donna ma
veramente
ok non è andata come pensavo però posso
fare questo guarda listino a tutti a non
vedono anche se sto cadendo dovrà cadere
ma fa niente
io ci credo
l'ho mancato di 40 metri prova niente
blu subito così forse troppo o forse no
poi vi sono staccati in cima e con il
fatto incredibile c'è le cure avere
impavido con zoe noi come cazzo dice
addio
e vabbè si sia la gara si ma sì e credo
ragazzi che ci sia anche
stavo per dire quello che vedo che il
passo se il turbo santo iddio va bene va
bene va bene baristi casi e marini vado
che stava andando lì non ci credo stavo
stava mancando l'obiettivo perché stiamo
dando troppo forte
mentre i camion le slot pazzesco lo zio
e la zia
merda
ci arriva oggi arriva solo quattro
ragazzi non so come ho fatto io ce l'ho
fatta in 31 secondi pazzesca sta roba
guardava è concluso qui il video
spero che vi sia piaciuto comunque io
sono stato veramente c'è secondo me
rispetto al mio solito questo questa è
stata prova di propaggine considerate
che non giocava sta roba da mille anni
quindi veramente non so come ho fatto a
trovare la forza di riuscire a fare
tutto questo non lo puoi passare non c'è
modo ma se esco concludo qua ragazzi
spero che viene sia piaciuto iscrivetevi
a chianale lasciate un commento è un mi
piace è niente noi ci vediamo ci vediamo
anche subito come sempre bella bella
ragazza
[Musica]